as you know there are plenty of people
who think that the suspicions about
Trump Russia connections are just
ridiculous conspiracy theories and that
the investigations are just witch hunts
one of the arguments used by people like
that is that Donald Trump hasn't
actually done anything or tried to do
anything that would benefit Russia so
what is Russia getting from it now this
is a silly argument at its face because
Trump is 4.5 months into his presidency
ok but it also happens to be wrong
first of all last week if you watch the
program last week I told you that Donald
Trump is planning to give Russia back
two compounds that the Obama
administration had taken from them last
December one in Maryland and one in New
York this is something Russia wants this
is something Russians have actually
tweeted about including thinly veiled
threats surrounding it as well those
compounds were used for Intel purposes
Obama kicked the Russians out of those
facilities in response to the Russian
interference with the 2016 election so
we had that right but now it gets even
bigger over the weekend we learned that
as soon as Donald Trump took office in
January his administration tried to
start the process of lifting several
sanctions on Russia according to
multiple White House and State
Department officials this included both
the sanctions that came after Russia
annexed Crimea in 2014 and sanctions
that were placed more recently after the
2016 Russian election hacking this was
completely unknown to the public at the
time but in the first weeks of Donald
Trump's presidency the administration
told the State Department start drafting
proposals to lift these economic
sanctions as well as to return the
Russian Intel compounds that I mentioned
earlier one State Department official
said that Donald Trump wanted to lift
the sanctions quote in exchange for
absolutely nothing
publicly maybe it seemed like nothing
but obviously there must have been
something that had been exchanged I
thought Trump was the big deal maker Pat
who trades for nothing unless Trump's
part of the deal came before is expected
to come later or was coerced
because of possible blackmail info that
Russia had at the time right and I think
this really goes to the idea that they
would have planned to do a lot more had
the public not been aware of your
scandal that's going on now and this
alarmed a bunch of State Department
officials that they started asking
congressional leaders please pass
legislation that will prevent this from
happening bills were proposed at the
time but they were shot down in
committee by Senate Foreign Relations
Committee Chairman bob corker a
Republican and one State Department
official said that the requests made him
feel quote deeply uncomfortable Dan
freed is a veteran State Department
official he says he received several
quote panicky calls from State
Department officials who had been asked
to create the sanction lifting proposals
and one official said to Dan freed
please my god can't you stop this and as
Pat suggested it is believed that the
administration stopped pursuing the
lifting of these sanctions after the
Michael Flynn situation completely
imploded for Optics reasons but once
again what is the underlying story here
the public revelations correlate with
what we believed was taking place behind
the scenes the conversations between
Trump and Russian officials to discuss
sanctions it's all falling into place
remember it's been widely reported that
some of Michael Flynn and Jared
Kushner's meetings with Russian
officials a month earlier were about
lifting sanctions and now we are
learning that during the first days of
the administration they were talking
about lifting sanctions in exchange for
nothing it's all self itself and
internally corroborating we've not found
anything so far where we can say that's
definitively not true about what we
suspected I think a lot of people who
question the Trump Russia controversy
are going after this idea that Trump
hasn't done enough to help Putin and the
Russians but they also questioned
whether or not Putin is helping Trump
maybe he's paying him or all these
things but I think I just getting him
elected is good enough I think that
would suffice whether or not Russia
flipped the election the idea of looking
for a list of stuff that has been
exchanged is already a false notion
we've found out about everything that's
taken place not because Trump
and whoever was involved in Russia
wanted us to find out about it at least
so it seems unless there's sort of like
a triple reverse layered conspiracy
theory of sorts so the idea that unless
you can find the list of who did what
for whom that there's nothing here I
think Pat is is a suit Lee pointing out
that it doesn't make sense
Jared Kushner's involvement here I be we
I don't have to rehash the entire thing
here but again these sanctions were
designed to incentivize Russia to change
its behavior they've done nothing to
deserve the lifting of these sanctions
with regard to the hacking or Ukraine
unless they've done something for Donald
Trump which would make him want to lift
the sanctions in exchange for nothing
and we will absolutely continue to cover
this send me your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show